so I filled my lessons everyday
sometimes a few times a day and I just
have it set up in my classroom it's just
there it took a little bit of time for
my students at the beginning to sort of
get used to
what's this setter what's going on but
now it's just part of the room it's
there I'll videotape and this a couple
that go up every day so that it's sort
of spaced out to encourage people toward
thinking about mathematics teaching I
think about a couple of things number
one our society it just relized so much
every aspect of our society relies on
things that are mathematical in nature
even when you wouldn't think that their
mathematical I mean there's the obvious
things which are numerical like when you
see statistics in the news and you think
well what does that really mean but in
addition to that I just think
mathematics is so fascinating when you
really understand it when you think
about okay I would say think about how
to tie my shoelaces that's like a simple
problem that you'd understand that
doesn't seem like there's any maths
involved in that but actually when you
think about all the different ways that
you can combine these strings and the
length of string and whole fields of
mathematics get developed out of things
like that and then it seems like they're
going anywhere but that's how we
understand DNA because DNA all these
knotted up twisted up little strings
basically and so to understand something
like that
to understand that hey there's
mathematics that could be beautiful and
elegant just like a symphony to know
that that's out there and the students
don't get to experience it is really sad
it's a little bit as though if students
had to learn about music theory but
never got to touch an instrument or
never got to hear Beethoven or enjoy a
pop song I really feel as though it's
the responsibility of mathematics
teachers to help students see to open
students eyes to how majestic and
insightful and powerful mathematics can
be and we're not going to get there
without some really really fantastic
teachers I think teaching at all levels
is all that relationship or high kind of
being taught that relationship is the
medium for learning if you don't have a
relationship with your teacher it's
really hard to really work together with
them to understand it really hard
concepts and wrap your head around
really difficult skills and so I took
that attitude into the classroom that
it's all about the relationship that you
form with your students and I've kind of
taken a similar approach to being a head
teacher and form your team and making a
coherent I think that the relationships
between the staff are key I think that
if you've got strong relationships a
faculty really flies and experiments and
it takes risks and it really pushes the
boundaries of what's possible look at me
Don
for anyone who's considering teaching
and especially teaching mathematics
there are a few professions out there I
think that are as purposeful as teaching
that when I walk into school the purpose
for why I come and do my job is in front
of me every single day and it's looking
at back at me
expecting where are we gonna go today
sir and what are we gonna see and what
are we gonna discover
and how are we gonna grow as people and
expand our minds that's the reason why I
come to work every day that purpose is
so clear I really believe in public
education because I think that number
one every student deserves without
having to necessarily be able to cover
the costs of it every student deserves
to be able to have a an environment that
they can walk you to where they don't
need to be worrying about where they
need to get their next meal or the next
you know support for home all those
kinds of things they've got people who
care for them people who are gonna help
them learn people who are going to help
them grow as human beings and develop
and mature in character and I think that
every student every trial deserves a
place like that that they can come to I
think that as a teacher my whole role is
to help students understand okay you're
here in this world you have so much to
learn
there's so much to learn about this big
wide world you need help to do it
and so for me I love to be able to reach
out to every child in this community to
say you know to every student as you
look down the street you see all these
houses and just the students only have
just Levi to say yeah I serve this
community like I have a really important
role in making sure that this community
is strong that it's full of really
responsible and educated citizens and I
play a pivotal role in that and that's
what public education means for me